I really I'm really interesting that
question I don't have time in my day job
to be an active reporter on it but I'm
really interested in it I ask everybody
i can ask in the foreign policy world
and i get a wide range of diverse
answers my own gut feeling prediction as
of today would be that the US will not
launch a strike against iran but that
Israel will launch a strike against Iran
so that that would be where I would come
out now but you know you hear many many
versions of this including the Bush
administration will do this as a sort of
last gesture a lot of people think that
I i I'm coming down against the idea
that that will happen
you